it was September of 2015 and the world
fell in love with pizza wrath this
determined little rodent served as a
symbol of many things to many different
people some saw themselves struggling
with dreams so big they seemed
impossible others saw reminder of how
gross New York City's subway is and for
the Nerds of the world aka me I saw
splitter carrying home a snack for the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to game haha it's not game
theory it's film theory that's the first
time I've screwed it up hello Internet
welcome to film Theory the only show on
the internet that can talk about mole
people radioactive isotopes and kids
movies all in a single episode don't
believe me challenge accepted and so it
goes another summer another go around
with everyone's favorite radiation
infused superhero no the other one
no the other other one who is that okay
let me be more specific here everyone's
favorite superhero who was doused with
radioactive chemicals the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles okay though it is worth
mentioning that the TNM tee were
originally meant to be a parody of
daredevil the devil of Hell's Kitchen I
can totally see the resemblance there
since the 1980s this franchise has been
cranking out comics cartoons live-action
movies action figures and breakfast
cereals and nothing has been able to
stop it not even Megan Fox's acting
and yet I have a confession in all that
time I still can't figure out the proper
occasions to use the word cowabunga
one day one day this longevity is doubly
impressive when you consider that the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles has to be
one of the weirdest most far-fetched
concepts ever I mean really sit there
and think about it four giant mutated
Turtles raised by a super intelligent
rat in the sewers under New York City
become pizza loving crime-fighting
ninjutsu masters who befriend one of New
York City's most noteworthy television
reporters who just so happens to be
totally cool keeping the biggest news
story ever a complete secret seriously
April O'Neill where is your journalistic
integrity
you got like eight Pulitzer Prize
winning stories here radioactive dumping
super mutants animals that can talk the
existence of aliens a ninja crime
syndicate run by a cheese grater
take your pick anyway the minimap Pat
that lives inside my heart desperately
wants the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
to be real so today we're gonna explore
how possible these things really are
you may laugh but hey anything can
happen in New York fist fights between
cartoon characters happen boba fett
playing the accordion happened mutant
reptiles in the sewers may have happened
because believe it or not there's a
pretty convincing argument to be made
that all the ingredients to making the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles might exist
in the sewer systems of New York now
before you go blowing up the comments
let's all take a breath for a second did
dress question one no I'm not off my
medication but thank you for your
concerns and number two no of course I'm
not claiming that the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles are real obviously this
whole universe is about as fictional as
again is there a nunchuck wielding
Terrapin who's gonna save you from being
mugged while using 80s slang in downtown
Manhattan sadly no but giant mutated
pizza eating Turtles beneath the city
cowabunga we're gonna find out did I do
it right no ah one day one day let's
start off pretty simple is it possible
that turtles like the ones we see in
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles could be in
New York City this one's easy
yes according to the tales of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles comic book
series specifically volume 2 issue
number 18 the Ninja Turtles are of the
red-eared slider species fun fact in the
wake of the first TMNT movie released in
1990 England was flooded with so many
red eared sliders as pets for children
that they became an invasive species
that clogged up the waterway so yeah in
an ironic twist the creation of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles actually
increased the likelihood that the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles could exist
and that my friends is life imitating
art now to an outsider it might seem
like the only place in New York City
that you're gonna find a turtle is in a
zoo or at the bottom of a suspicious
bowl of soup but in fact there are red
eared sliders living wild in the middle
of Manhattan within Central Park
there's a large pond where turtles
congregate that is plainly named the
Turtle Pond according to the Central
Park Conservancy there are five turtle
species living wild inside that pond the
most numerous of which is none other
than the red eared slider and red eared
sliders aren't like beta fish that you
buy one week and flush the next these
little guys can live between 50 and 70
years so there are bound to be some
teenage turtles in the mix check that
one off the list okay it's a big deal
the right kind of turtle is found in New
York City but can you find
them in the sewer system again it's an
easy yes The Associated Press reported
in 1990 that turtles are commonly found
in New York sewers with some large ones
up to 50 pounds in weight now some of
you might argue that in each of the
live-action Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
movies we've seen the turtles and
splinter living in fairly spacious
underground dwellings and that nothing
like that would even be possible in the
sewer system but a closer look at the
movie suggests that turtles might live
somewhere else underground in the first
live-action Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
movie April O'Neill gets mugged by the
foot while she's waiting on a subway
platform
Raphael fights them off carrying a
knocked out April back to the turtles
hideouts but interestingly he gets there
by going down the subway tunnel and
while we see the turtles and what are
clearly sewer and drainage pipes there's
nothing there to indicate that their
home base is necessarily in the sewer
instead it would make more sense for
them to be around and abandoned a train
tunnel these tunnels are gonna make much
better living corners much less
susceptible to flooding and much less
likely to reek of pop and there's plenty
of proof that people can survive in the
abandoned train tunnels under New York
one of the best pieces of evidence would
be the 2000 documentary dark days which
shows an entire underground community
for the homeless in an abandoned train
tunnel it's sequestered it's roomy and
it can even get electricity sometimes
and it's not like this is a unique thing
either there are literally dozens of
unused underground tunnels and train
stations sprinkled throughout New York
City
therefore it's plausible that the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles can find a
subterranean hideout that not only fits
their needs but keeps them in the
shadows you know since the new movie is
out of the shadows anyway at this point
we've got teenage turtles of the right
species who could be living under New
York but now for the question that
thousands of middle schoolers have asked
for ages can a turtle eat pizza yes
red eared sliders are omnivores and will
eat pretty much anything cowabunga was
that right one day one day so we have
teenage turtles in the New York sewers
who eat pizza what's left well mutants
and ninja and since we can't have them
learning ninjutsu until they're walking
on two legs and wielding a bo staff look
at the mutant part of the equation so
what do we know about the mutations
that's fictional Turtles experience we
get a fairly clear explanation in the
second feature film the secret of use
here's what professor Perry says about
the TGR I use that caused the turtle
commuting an unknown mixture of
discarded chemicals was accidentally
exposed to a series of radiating waves
and the resulting food was found to have
remarkable but dangerous mutilate genic
properties
all right I'll forgive the fact that dr.
science here uses the made-up word
mutant a genic he means mutagenic and
instead focus on the idea that the
turtles were exposed to some radioactive
toxic waste and this caused them to grow
to their incredible size so is there any
real-world proof that radiation plus
organism equals giant indeed there is in
the years following the Fukushima
nuclear disaster in Japan in 2011 there
were numerous reports of very strange
wildlife in the waters off the coast for
example here's a picture of a regular
wolf fish and now compare it to the
picture of this giant mutated bull fish
caught off the coast in 2015 ah kill it
kill it with fire burn you demon spawn
but seriously I would eat that in a
sushi restaurant any day
now some might claim that it's hard to
prove that this nightmarish wolf fish
was definitely a product of mutation
caused by radioactive material but when
you consider the fact that the waters
near Fukushima feature radiation counts
over 2,500 times the legal limit it's a
pretty likely culprit especially cuz
out of proportion parts of its body arms
look he'll it's not like there's some
source of nuclear radiation leaching
into New York City sewer system right I
mean who would be dumb enough to place a
nuclear power plant just a few miles
away from the most densely populated
city in America
ah the 1970s
that's who Indian Point Energy Center is
a large three unit nuclear power plant
that was built about thirty six miles
away from midtown Manhattan and opened
its doors in 1974 well there haven't
been any major disasters at Indian point
in its 40-year history
in early 2016 yeah this year it was
reported that radioactive material from
Indian Point was leaking into the
groundwater and a greatly accelerated
rate how much more radiation than normal
you asked eighty percent across the
board and one well in particular showed
a 65,000 percent increase and the most
prominent contaminants was tritium a
radioactive isotope that's known to
cause mutations so much for green energy
unless you like your energy green
because it's glowing from radioactivity
and my rights
boom Ching so how much would this affect
New York City the endpoint is located
upstream of Gotham right on the banks of
the Hudson River
these same Hudson River that flows to
the west of the Bronx and Manhattan
looks like the bodies of mafia
informants aren't the only thing
polluting the Hudson these days but doom
Ching again if those elevated levels of
radiation somehow are able to make their
way down to the Hudson River and into
New York City's water table that waste
could end up anywhere including in the
sewers beneath Manhattan
red eared sliders fresh out of Central
Park still I know this all sounds
ridiculous I mean sure the Indian Point
Energy Center opened up in the mid-1970s
which is exactly the right time since
the first live-action movie was released
in 1990 and in it Splinter says that the
turtles are 15 years old weird but that
doesn't mean anything I mean if the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles were really
real we'd expect to see a sharp drop-off
in violent crime in New York City
starting around 1990 and what what's
that that's exactly what's happened kaua
King Bunga but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and cuts welcome back to
the supervision tournament where oh we
have not done one of these in a while
it's gonna be bad so today's questions a
really simple one which turtle is your
favorite leonardo Donatello Michelangelo
or Raphael seriously do people really
like Raphael Leonardo and Donatello all
the way Leonardo cuz he has to cool
swords Donatello cuz his color is purple
hey no shame in a guy liking the color
purple click on one to cast your vote
and find out next week which turtle
happens to be the film theorist
viewership favorite heroes in a half
shell turtle power next week a different
take on some undersea action